Якщо ми не дотягнемо цю війну,
то ви ж розумієте, що іншого шансу у нас вже не буде.
Ми зараз набираємо людей, які нам
потрібні були на вчора, навіть не на сьогодні.
600 людей вбили їхніх,
через два дні там вже нові 600 людей.
У нас, на жаль, такої можливості немає.
У нас там 100 втратили, 20 прийшло.
От зараз кажуть: поміняємо головкома.
Ну, не проблема, поміняйте. На кого?
Ну, хто ще так витягне, як він?
Його, Валерія Федоровича, так бачать люди.
Будь-який після нього призначений Головком,
мені дуже буде, незалежно від того,
кого там призначать, мені буде дуже шкода ту людину.
Якщо в минулому році можна було ставити якісь прогнози,
то цей тяжкий 2023 рік показав,
що ніякі прогнози не спрацьовують.
Я розумію, що всі втомилися від війни, всім тяжко.
Але ми маємо розуміти, що ми маємо це перетерпіти,
вижити і зробити свою справу для того,
щоб наші діти були вільними.
Сьогодні спілкуємося з генералом ЗСУ,
очільником оборони Миколаєва
на початку повномасштабного вторгнення РФ в Україну,
а також людиною з близького військового оточення
головнокомандувача ЗСУ Залужного Дмитром Марченком.
Пане Дмитро, вітаю вас.
Пане Дмитро, наразі досить гостро стоїть
питання мобілізації в Україні.
Ось на нещодавній підсумковій прес-конференції
президент Зеленський зазначив,
що від військових є запит на ще 500 тисяч мобілізованих
в Україні. Наразі яким чином можна
їх мобілізувати та в які терміни?
Ну, це дуже гостре питання, яке зараз стоїть.
На жаль. Ті добровольці,
які хотіли добровільно піти до лав ЗСУ для того,
щоб чинити опір, вони закінчилися.
І ми побачили нову проблему, з якою не стикалися раніше,
що люди не дуже розуміють того стану,
в якому зараз опинилися ті,
хто воюють вже два роки.
Тобто люди виснажені. Їм треба відпочити,
їм треба відновити сили.
І для того, щоб це зробити, в нас мають бути резерви.
Я думаю, що спільними зусиллями
з місцевими органами самоврядування, з поліцейськими,
з військовими ми таки зможемо донести
до нашої чоловічої половини України ту інформацію,
що воно потрібно, потрібно чинити опір.
Якщо ми не дотягнемо цю війну, то ви ж розумієте,
що іншого шансу у нас вже не буде.
Ну, а саме 500 тисяч людей -
в які терміни можливо їх мобілізувати?
Ну, звісно, що це буде не один день,
це будуть етапи, це буде чіткий розподіл.
Я думаю, що в генеральному штабі є на то плани,
є на то запити. Сказати точно, коли це буде
і як якісно, я не можу і навіть не знаю,
хто може це вам сказати. Наразі є розуміння,
куди, для чого і навіщо вони.
Розуміння, як це вийде, як це здійснити фізично,
то розуміння поки в мене точно його немає.
На мобілізацію цих 500 тисяч українців
потрібно 500 мільярдів гривень, казав президент.
На що саме у мобілізаційному процесі необхідна така сума?
Ну, ви ж розумієте, що кожного солдата треба одягнути,
його треба навчити, його треба нагодувати.
Тобто ці кошти, вони саме для того,
щоб зі звичайної цивільної людини зробити бійця,
який впевнено буде себе вести на полі бою.
А це досить недешево коштує, ми це всі розуміємо.
Повернуться бійці на відновлення: їх треба одягнути,
їм треба відремонтувати техніку,
їх треба нагодувати, їх треба полікувати.
Це теж кошти. Тобто це цілий комплекс,
який має бути виконаний.
Якщо ми його не виконаємо, то я не знаю, що буде завтра.
Ви ж бачите, що як ми несемо втрати,
так і ворог несе. Ворог несе дуже великі втрати.
Але ворог навчився їх дуже швидко поповнювати
і ми маємо робити так, щоб не відставати від цих темпів.
А зараз відстаємо?
Зараз, на жаль, трошки відстаємо.
Верховна Рада підтримала зниження порогу
мобілізаційного віку, з 27 до 25 років.
Президент поки що не підписав законопроєкт.
На його думку, недостатньо аргументів у цьому рішенні.
Ви як військова людина як ставитесь до такої ініціативи?
Ну, я ставлюся дуже позитивно,
тому що, ну, ви ж розумієте, коли йдуть чоловіки
віком 50-55 років, а в той час 25-річні хлопці
не мобілізуються, це не дуже справедливо.
Тобто 25 років - це і є той стан людини,
будь-якого чоловіка, як кажуть, в розквіті сил.
І якщо ви подивитеся на тих, хто воює з того боку,
то там основна маса - це молоді хлопці.
Ми розуміємо, з ким ми воюємо,
це переважаючі, дуже переважаючі сили.
І ми мали бути до цього готові,
ми мали про це думати, і це вкрай необхідний просто захід.
Чи підтримуєте ви ідею мобілізації жінок в Україні?
Ну, я скажу так, за бажанням.
Якщо жінка бажає, то вона може призватися.
Якщо вона не бажає, то закривати дірки жінками в той час,
коли купа чоловіків ховається десь за кордоном…
Ну, я не знаю, як вони потім повернуться
і будуть цим жінкам дивитися в очі.
Але жінки, яких вже досить багато воює на фронті, ефективні?
Так, є такі жінки, які можуть підняти чоловіків
і повести в бій. Ви ж розумієте,
що ставити жінку на рівень бійця штурмового підрозділу -
це не дуже правильно.
Чому?
Тому що там є дуже сильні фізичні навантаження,
які, на жаль, ви ж розумієте, що жінка не може
пробігти 10 кілометрів з 40 кілограмами на плечах.
Тому, крім того, що ми штурмуємо,
в нас ще є дуже багато таких обов'язків,
роботи, яка не потребує там значних фізичних зусиль.
І саме там вони можуть себе проявляти дійсно
як професіонали, як люди, які потрібні.
Ми не можемо порівнюватися з Ізраїлем,
тому що у них це на законодавчому рівні
вже не перший рік. Тобто вони перед тим,
як призивати дівчат і жінок, вони їх дуже потужно готують.
І це у них відбувається постійно.
Постійні ротації, постійні навчання.
У нас геть інша обстановка,
у нас геть інше відношення до цього.
А чи є рекрутинг в ЗСУ дієвим у процесі мобілізації?
Ну, рекрути є, але, на жаль, ми маємо зараз об'єднати
всі зусилля військових, цивільних, силових структур
не для того, щоб виходити на вулиці і ловити цих військових,
а для того, щоб пояснювати, що це обов'язок
кожного зараз захищати свою домівку.
Треба трошки поміняти підхід.
Робити в даний час якусь реформу, призову,
чи процесу мобілізації, ну, я думаю, що це не дуже вчасно.
Тому що ми розуміємо, що ми зараз набираємо людей,
які нам потрібні були на вчора, навіть не на сьогодні.
І тому, ви ж розумієте, що кожна реформа може відбутися,
а може і не відбутися. Тому ризикувати на даний час,
ким вийшло, а потім, вибачте, не вийшло,
ми не маємо права.
Головнокомандувач ЗСУ Валерій Залужний зазначив,
що воєнкоми у регіонах, яких масово звільнили
цьогоріч у серпні, цитую, "були професіоналами".
"Вони знали, як це робити, тобто мобілізувати, а їх немає".
Володіючи ситуацією, зокрема, на півдні,
ви бачите, як звільнення цих воєнкомів
вплинуло на мобілізацію?
Так, я відчуваю. Це не те, що відчуваю, я це бачу.
На жаль, воєнком - це така дуже специфічна професія.
Це не можна просто взяти будь-якого майора
або підполковника, призначити й сказати,
що від сьогодні ти будеш воєнкомом
і ти маєш робити ту складну роботу.
Так, були певні проблеми. Так дуже...
Була розвинута корупція.
Але для цього є відповідні органи,
які мали з цим боротися. Тобто знімати...
Ви ж розумієте, що не всі були поганими воєнкомами.
Погані люди є всюди. Вони є і були, і будуть.
І навіть серед тих, яких нових попризначали,
повірте мені, що будуть випадки,
коли вони будуть займатися неправомірними діями.
Але для цього є відповідні органи.
Вони мали з цим боротися.
Просто так знімати всіх професіоналів,
призначати туди просто людей з боку, я думаю,
що це не вирішить проблем. Вони ж не вкрали вчора,
або сьогодні, або на минулому тижні.
Вони це робили роками.
І роками хтось на це закривав очі.
Ну, серед інших були і професіонали,
які не займалися цим. Ми мали зробити так,
щоб вони не крали і не брали хабарі.
Оце ми мали зробити. Це ДБР, це СБУ. Це прокуратура.
Але загалом ось ці нові зміни, нові воєнкоми,
вони справляються з тими потребами мобілізації?
Ми це побачимо, коли ми будемо набирати ту
кількість людей, яка нам потрібна.
Але станом на нині ви бачите, що відбувається.
Це оці походи по містах. Це заходи в квартири,
в приватні сектори, до людей додому.
Це точно не їхній обов'язок,
і вони точно не мають цього права робити.
Але вони змушені, тому що ви ж розумієте,
що змушені керівники поповнювати втрати.
Ми змушені це робити. Якщо ми цього не будемо робити,
то рано чи пізно у зв'язку з втратами підрозділи
будуть закінчуватися і в зв'язку з тим будуть
втрачатися території. Цього ми не можемо допустити.
Ви не раз публічно заявляли, що не хочете
коментувати наявність візійного конфлікту
між Генштабом і Офісом президента. Чому так?
У нас у державі відбувається війна.
І зараз ми маємо бути мудрішими,
сильнішими і розумнішими. І ми зараз маємо
не про конфлікти думати, а як сісти всім за один стіл,
спланувати і відбити ворога.
Я не хочу ніяких конфліктів.
Я скажу, що для мене 24 числа...
Була проведена так от червона лінія.
І почалося життя без політики, без якихось вподобань,
без нічого. Я думаю, що в наших керівників
на високому рівні вистачить мудрості зробити так,
щоб не було ніяких конфліктів.
Насправді я думаю, що конфлікт...
Він не стільки є конфлікт, скільки його роздувають.
Тому не проблема сісти, потиснути руки
і йти далі бити ворога. І я враховую,
що цим саме і мають вони зайнятися.
Закінчиться війна, потім, будь ласка, розбирайтесь.
Це у нас херсонський дизайнер є такий, є Telegram-канал.
І він відтворює те, як сприймають нас люди.
Прислав мені Валерія Федоровича.
Його бачать, Валерія Федоровича, так бачать люди.
Він, я вам скажу, він такий доволі буває жорстким,
доволі іноді м'яким. Тобто в нього цей баланс -
він витриманий. І це в принципі дуже добре.
Ну, мені тяжко, я уявляю, як йому тяжко.
Ну, те, що він на себе взяв, це дуже велика
відповідальність. От зараз кажуть:
поміняємо головкома. Ну, не проблема, поміняйте.
На кого? Ну, хто ще так витягне, як він?
Я вам скажу, що будь-який після нього
назначений головком, мені дуже буде, незалежно від того,
кого там призначать, мені буде дуже шкода ту людину.
Бо він буде приречений, що кожну його дію
будуть розбирати по частинкам…
Якщо до цього вже всі звикли, якщо цей у найтяжчий час
проявив себе і витримав нашу країну, то, ну,
дещо йому можуть пробачити.
То новому, кого призначать,
йому пробачати нічого не будуть.
Нещодавно стало відомо про прослуховування кабінету
головкома Залужного. Ви спілкувалися з ним про це?
Я спілкуюся з Валерієм Федоровичем виключно
по моїй роботі, по тому, що я зараз роблю
на півдні України.
"Українська правда", посилаючись на свої джерела
у спецслужбі, стверджує, що "прослушку"
також виявили у кількох підлеглих
Валерія Федоровича. Ви є серед них?
Та я якось, знаєте, коли людина просто собі працює,
робить свою справу чесно, ну, хай прослуховують.
Мені нема що ховати, я не займаюсь якимись
неправомірними діями, я ніяким чином
зараз не задіяний до якихось коштів
і до якихось закупівель. Але якщо стоїть "прослушка",
то тут є один єдиний негатив: хто це прослуховує?
І чи не вилізе та інформація,
яка мається на цьому прослуховуванні,
далі і не буде якогось витоку інформації до нашого ворога.
Я за це тільки переймаюся.
Але "прослушки" - ну так, кожного держслужбовця
можуть прослуховувати. І кожен розуміє,
що якщо він там займає певну посаду,
ну, цього в наш час, мабуть, не уникнути.
Ну, ви не знаходили у себе за час повномасштабної війни?
Я їх не шукав. Якщо хтось слухає, то вибачте,
якщо я там висловлююсь нецензурною лексикою.
Я виконую ті заходи, які залежать від мене.
Тобто я постійно міняю місце помешкання,
місце роботи, для того, щоб, ви розумієте,
це необхідні заходи. Але проводити на кожному
місці там якісь перевірки прослуховування,
я думаю, воно мені не потрібно.
Щодо корупційних скандалів у міноборони
за очільництва міністра Резнікова, ви казали,
що причина була, цитую, "у поганому оточенні міністра".
Після кадрових змін у міністерстві як,
на вашу думку, працює нова команда?
Ну поки що рано казати, як працює нова команда.
Ми це побачимо за результатами їхньої роботи
як мінімум через рік. Я думаю, неправильно буде
оцінювати людину, яка тільки починає розбиратися в тому,
що їй довірили. Все це покажеться,
все це ми побачимо через рік.
Так само ви вважаєте щодо питання,
чи вирішилася проблема корупції з приходом нових облич?
Ну, я не знаю, цим мають займатися компетентні органи,
я не можу давати таку оцінку.
Добігає кінця 2023 рік, другий рік повномасштабної війни
в Україні. Наразі українські та іноземні посадовці,
воєначальники, експерти дуже по-різному називають
той етап війни, на якому ми перебуваємо.
І "кризовий етап", і "вирішальний", навіть "глухий кут".
Як, на вашу думку, можна правильно назвати
цей етап війни з РФ?
У мене були там якісь мої особисті думки,
але дуже тяжко щось назвати,
на якому етапі ми знаходимося. Дуже тяжко.
Якщо в минулому році можна було ставити якісь прогнози,
то цей тяжкий 2023 рік показав, що ніякі прогнози
не спрацьовують. Я можу проаналізувати те,
що робиться на моєму напрямку. На напрямку зараз
дуже тяжкий етап. Але давайте ми не будемо
підказувати нашому ворогу. Наші війська, морська піхота,
піхота, артилерія відбили плацдарм, зайшли, закріпилися.
Що буде далі? Ви будете спостерігати.
Командувач угрупування військ "Таврія"
генерал Тарнавський нещодавно розповів,
що ЗСУ скоротили деякі військові операції
через нестачу артснарядів та іноземної
допомоги по всій лінії фронту.
Наскільки ситуація критична саме
на вашому, південному напрямку?
Я не відкрию військової таємниці, якщо скажу,
що нам дуже не вистачає артилерійських снарядів.
На жаль, це воно так і є.
Але в будь-яких умовах ми пристосовуємося до того,
що маємо. Тобто у нас немає артилерійських снарядів.
Зараз за допомогою волонтерів ми поставили акцент
на FPV-дрони. Тобто вони виконують задачу
артилерії і навіть на деяких напрямках кращі,
ніж артилерія. Тому не буде снарядів -
ми будемо пристосовуватися.
Не буде у нас тяжкої техніки - ми будемо
пристосовуватися. Ми будемо міняти плани,
ми будемо міняти тактику,
підхід до виконання бойових задач.
Але нам нічого не залишається.
Ми будемо стояти, ми будемо воювати.
Ну, але наразі та потуга, той ресурс,
який є в армії РФ, дає їм можливість
просунутися найближчим часом десь на якихось ділянках?
Ну, ті сили і засоби, які ми бачимо,
які зараз перекинули по лінії фронту,
їх достатньо на проведення якихось штурмових дій,
але їх недостатньо, припустімо,
для захоплення Миколаєва, або захоплення Харкова,
або захоплення Запоріжжя.
Я знаю, що найбільш основна задача -
це на сході України вийти на адміністративні кордони
або захопити хоч якісь міста, щоб показати,
у виправдання цієї війни, своїм людям,
що у них є якийсь успіх.
Я знаю, що на півдні у них стоїть задача
хоча б не втратити те, що вони вже мають.
Але я ж не розумію їхніх стратегічних планів.
Можливо, завтра вони приймуть рішення,
що їм потрібно захопити Запоріжжя, Миколаїв і Одесу.
І ми маємо до цього готуватися зараз.
Ми маємо це теж прораховувати,
ми маємо створити три лінії оборони,
ми маємо робити фортецю з міст,
ми маємо до цього готуватися.
Контрнаступ у 2022 році завершився деокупацією
північних регіонів, Харківщини,
правобережжя Херсонщини.
Цьогоріч Генштаб визнає, що контрнаступ у 2023 році
не виправдав тих очікувань звільнити решту територій.
Що відрізняло ці два контрнаступи?
Ну, по характеру ведення бойових дій.
Тобто ви розумієте, що кожне ведення бойових дій,
воно має свою назву. Це або рейдові дії,
або контрнаступальні дії, або оборонні.
І відповідно до кожних із цих дій є певний перелік заходів,
які проводяться. Тобто контрнаступ -
це підтримка з повітря, це артилерійська підготовка,
це штурмові дії. Ну, це такий дуже потужний комплекс
заходів, який проводиться для того,
щоб пробити лінію оборони.
А тоді це не відбувалося по одній простій причині.
Тоді не було лінії оборони у Російської Федерації.
Тобто вони наступали, вони не оборонялися.
Для того, щоб нам відбити їх і гнати далі,
нам потрібні були ресурси, яких у нас на той час,
на жаль, не вистачало. У 22-му році, я маю на увазі.
У 23-му році там… Дуже правильні,
хороші контрнаступальні дії, але, на жаль,
для того, щоб їх проводити, ми маємо розуміти,
що в нас має бути достатньо артилерії,
достатньо бронетехніки, достатньо ППО
і достатньо авіації. Якщо щось із цього недостатньо,
цей контрнаступ не буде таким вдалим,
прогнозованим, якщо чогось немає.
Але не мали всього необхідного на момент контрнаступу
і все одно вирішили спробувати?
Ми не вирішили спробувати, ми змушені були це робити,
тому що ви ж розумієте, що будь-яке затишшя,
бездіяльність, воно дає їм право переформовувати
підрозділи, закріплятися або створити оборону.
І саме основне, це не дати ворогу нас взяти у кільце,
у щільне кільце, як вони зробили це в Маріуполі.
І ми з цією задачею впоралися.
Екскомандувач армії США у Європі Бен Ходжес
раніше прогнозував, що ЗСУ військовим шляхом
звільнять Крим влітку 23-го року,
але за умови вчасного надання західної зброї.
Попри затримку озброєння, він досі переконаний,
що Крим деокупують військовим шляхом.
Ви поділяєте цю думку зараз?
Ну, звісно, поділяю. Я військовий, я розумію,
що всі території нашої держави ми будемо звільняти
військовим шляхом. Якщо, може, відбудеться диво
і Путін помре, то тоді, може, щось поміняється.
Але поки що ми налаштовані на те,
щоб звільняти наші території військовим шляхом.
Ну, я не знаю. Ви ж розумієте, це людина,
яка не визнає помилок, яка не визнає програшів.
Тобто вона назад точно не здасть.
У них все поставлено на ці військові рейки,
і воно все йде собі своєчасно.
Тобто на Запорізькому напрямку там 600
людей вбили їхніх, через два дні там вже нові 600 людей.
У нас, на жаль, такої можливості немає.
У нас там 100 втратили, 20 прийшло.
На жаль, це і є основною проблемою.
Зараз там включати якихось експертів і розказувати,
що ви там погано спланували, що "ви там неправильно
працювали…" Є факти і фактори, які на це впливають,
на жаль. І це точно не проблема
планування і командування.
Улітку ви розповіли в одному з інтерв'ю,
що як генерал на півдні наразі співпрацюєте
з українськими партизанами на окупованих
південних територіях. Ця співпраця триває і зараз?
Так, це дуже щільна робота.
Я ж говорю, що є у нас такий телеграм-канал.
Раніше він був більш південний.
Зараз, наскільки я розумію, він вже такий став
національного масштабу. Це "Ніколаєвський Ваньок".
Це людина, яка дуже щільно працює.
Спілкується і працює з людьми на тому боці,
з проукраїнськи налаштованими,
які надають нам цінну інформацію. І завдяки цьому ми
вдало наносимо вогневі ураження по переміщенню
їхньої техніки під час їхнього наступу.
Ну, а з їхнього боку тут ще досі багато таких партизанів?
На жаль, вони теж дуже швидко адаптуються.
Вони теж роблять такі ж самі телеграм-канали.
Вони теж залучають сюди проросійськи налаштованих
людей. Ну, тобто ви ж розумієте, що південь України,
як би це не звучало прикро, але він більш проросійський,
ніж інші міста України. Тому тут є певна кількість людей.
Їх небагато, але їх і немало, які, в принципі,
чекають на "руський мир".
Ви генерал, який успішно провів оборону Миколаєва
під час повномасштабного вторгнення РФ на його початку.
У чому полягала тоді ваша тактика?
У кожному ОТГ, у кожному селі були мисливці за головами,
з місцевим головою, вони слідкували,
навіть коли ми їх просили, навіть виїжджали,
дивилися, коли вони намагалися обходити село
чи якусь місцевість, вони навіть виїжджали
і доповідали нам кількість техніки,
в якому напрямку. Це нам давало перевагу в тому,
що ми могли чітко переставити вогневі засоби
і вчасно відкрити вогонь артилерії,
для того, щоб ми їх не підпускали.
Навіть не дали їм понюхати Миколаєва!
Що у нас відбувалося на початку вторгнення:
оце Миколаїв. Зайшли спочатку на цей аеропорт.
У цей час тут вже були побудовані з Херсонського боку
колони. Тут стояла колона, тут стояла колона,
тут стояла колона. Росіян.
У Снігувівці стояла колона. Друга ось, бачите,
тут прямо і все. Все, що нам доповідали люди,
ми все наносили на карту. Це все відтворено з тих подій.
Тобто вони були тут, вони були тут.
Тобто вони вже, по суті, взяли у нас кільце.
Я вам скажу, що оборона Миколаєва, я вважаю,
що вона трошки недооцінена в масштабах цієї війни
в Україні. Можливо наш спротив,
він і змусив росіян піти з Києва.
Але ризик був наскільки великий?
Ну, я вам скажу чесно, що 3 березня я вже готував місто
до оточення. Тобто я вже прийшов до Віталія Кіма
і сказав, що нам треба робити запаси води, запаси їжі,
боєприпасів, палива. Ми вже готувалися до боїв у місті
і до щільного оточення міста.
І три дні вони мали дійти до Одеси батальйонними
тактичними групами через паромні переправи,
які вони мали покласти, три штуки.
Тобто операція насправді у них була продумана
досить потужно. Але в Миколаєві у них щось
пішло не так.
Успішну оборону Миколаєва часто порівнюють
з неуспіхом оборони на сусідній Херсонщині.
Які фактори завадили вдало захистити сусідній регіон?
Я скажу, що одним із ключових моментів,
чому це відбулося з Херсоном, це місцева влада.
Це місцева влада, це СБУ.
Це люди, які не чинили опір, які не готували ні людей,
ні війська, ні силові структури.
Ну... Це просто спрацював план росіян,
де вони зробили так, що там вийшов мер міста
і сказав, що не треба ні з ким сперечатись,
не треба воювати, нічого страшного, ми маємо жити,
ми маємо не вмирати. І в принципі
основну роль зіграло саме це.
Тобто це була не непідготовленість, а свідома здача?
Свідома здача, так. Я вам скажу,
як у нас відбулося по Вознесенську.
Голова однієї з районних адміністрацій сів
на танк російський і провів їх до Вознесенська,
не пересікаючи жодної дороги, де у нас уже були
поставлені блокпости, де їх чекали.
А він по полях їх завів саме в місто.
Просто так, що їх не побачив ніхто.
І ми змушені вже були їх вибивати з міста.
Я вам скажу, вони готували Миколаїв до здачі.
Наскільки за повномасштабну війну вдалося
удосконалити тактику та ефективність
Збройних Сил України, враховуючи все, що вже було?
Я вважаю, що ми ще на етапі удосконалення.
Те, що вчора ми врахували, що воно найправильніше,
найновіше, найтехнологічніше, вже сьогодні
для нас це пройдений етап.
Озброєння, ведення тактики, підхід до підготовки.
Ми маємо дуже вчасно і дуже швидко змінюватися.
Змінювати відношення до планування дій,
відношення до проведення бойових дій
і більш ставити акцент не на людський ресурс,
а на високі технології. Це розвідувальні дрони,
це дрони-камікадзе, це високоточне озброєння.
Які найвірогідніші сценарії розвитку війни
в Україні у 2024 році?
Перемога. Про інші ми просто не думаємо.
Але в ЗСУ допускають інші сценарії,
аби спланувати і підготуватися?
Ми готуємося до найгірших сценаріїв,
але сподіваємося на найкращі.
А найгірші сценарії - це які?
Давайте ми не будемо паніку наганяти
і не давати росіянам це все перекидати на ІПСО.
А скільки взагалі таких сценаріїв?
Ну, то, що він не один - це 100%, але їх не так і багато.
Ми прораховуємо всі ці випадки, всі ці сценарії.
Ми маємо до них бути готові.
Я ж кажу, що поки в нас є можливість,
нам треба зариватися, нам треба створити оборонні
рубежі, нам треба заливатися бетоном
і робити фортеці з міст, щоб ворог розумів,
що ці міста їм не пройти.
Наближаються різдвяно-новорічні свята.
Що б ви хотіли б побажати і військовим,
і цивільним в Україні в цей час?
Я думаю, що зараз у всіх бажання одне -
це повернутися додому до своїх сімей
і в нашому випадку бути цілим, здоровим і живим.
Цивільним я би бажав витримки.
Я розумію, що всі втомилися від війни, всім тяжко.
Але ми маємо розуміти, що ми маємо це перетерпіти,
вижити і зробити свою справу для того,
щоб наші діти були вільними.
Дуже дякую вам за цю розмову.